and I can only judge by the autopsy and
there are vastly more people out there
that know more about anything outside
that Morgan I do but I it just doesn't
make sense that what we saw at the
morgue what we did it to more and what I
participate in like the brain you know
there were two FBI agents that said
there was no brain Paul said there was
no brain but yet dr. Humes took a brain
out of the cranium handed it to dr.
Boswell and talked to Boswell and I went
over and I knelt down and he gave me to
the brain I turned it upside down and
put it in a sling you did I did help
John Kennedy's brain yes well I assumed
it was john f kennedy's brother that's
one other part right so great and but
you know as the book describes and in
that I don't know if I've been asked
many times is it was it john f kennedy's
brain do you think it was i haven't i
really don't have any any way of knowing
and neither does anyone else
unless somebody who who really
participated in in you know covering up
some parts of the assassination can come
forth and say now i'm also custom mystic
in that since there's so much stuff
that's come out that if i relate it back
to what i saw and so forth there's
always a question about it it sounds
like you believe it's important for us
to know the truth on what happened but
you also believe that if it's a
government investigation being done
whoever's involved on the unsaid if it's
only the government controlling and not
on the other side we're only going to
get the answer from somebody's on the
inside well for instance I've worked
with a friend of mine who's a
neurologist I've tried to be allowed to
go into the archives and review the
photographs and any evidence that they
have there I've been denied but yet he
he was allowed in
and to see the x-rays and so forth now
those x-rays I participate in I actually
helped position of the body and so forth
and when the first set of x-rays that we
did I remember the first photographs
when the head was first unwrapped they
took photographs all during the autopsy
and I was busy so I really wasn't paying
much attention to that but there's a
photographs from the Fox photographs
they're strange but let me ask you this
because you said you didn't have
interest but why were you asking to want
to get the photographs it was there a
moment where you kind of felt obligated
to want to find out again some answers
because well it sounds like there's a
little bit of conflicted like the
willingness that these are and also at
the same time wanted to stay away three
years ago I committed to this to writing
this book and all of this has occurred
within that time frame so you asked for
the photographs on the last three years
oh yeah so your desire to want to go
deeper on this is the last three years
well I have talked to you like say a
friend of mine the neurologist and he
and I have discussed what he saw in the
archives and what I remember seeing or
what I actually participated in and
remember seeing we've come to some
conclusions but not really the things
that I would consider to be emphatically
true okay
as far as participating in this three
years ago when I when I finally agreed
to do this if William wood would furnish
because I I'm basically finding in
medicine and science and I'm not a
journalist or a writer and he agreed to
help with you then his first suggestion
was that I need to start reading the
material I started a couple of books but
then I began to realize that if I read
all of this material then I may have a
little brain melt you know and it might
come in because you know 50-year old
memories or are difficult enough to
begin with so I stopped doing that and
then I began to talk
the people that I knew we're at Bethesda
not necessarily anymore but we're at
Bethesda and then I I was fortunate
enough to be able to talk to the honor
guard people gentleman named Dennis
David who was in charge of a detail that
actually he was an e6 who became an
officer later on and he served for
eleven years I think right yeah what did
he tell you when you spoke to him well
he he and I talked about the unloading
of the body from from the black hearse
Dennis gave me more of a time frame than
anything else because I was in the
morgue actually from about 3:30 in the
afternoon to about eight nine o'clock
the next morning
you knew the body was coming we were
told about he was coming yes